Andrew: The thing that we talk about a lot
is we don't control the outcome, we don't
control other people. We just need to focus
on what we do. I think they really embrace
that. They weren't focused on who was ranked
in front of them, who was ranked behind them.
They were focused on what we were going to
do when we were there.
Emily: It was really exciting. Going into
the DMR, we knew we had a shot at winning
it, so that was on all our minds, but I didn't
want to think about it because I didn't want
the pressure of "Oh my gosh, we're going to
win." All the girls did such an amazing job
in the DMR of handing off exactly where the
next leg needed to be. It's been a good experience
but a hard one for sure.
Andrew: We're really students first and foremost.
A lot of the kids that we compete with are
just athletes.
Corinne: I think that being a Hillsdale College
student athlete is just so rewarding, that
you're working hard on and off the track.
Our team motto is excellence, and that's always
what we're trying to pursue at practice, at
the meets, up the hill in the classrooms.
We want to be excellent every day.